hello everyone and Welcome to our
today's webinar steer tank bioreactors
and vaccine development producing aav
particles and covid-19 Spike proteins in
suspension culture my name is David
zolbar I am the Global Marketing Manager
for our bioprocess products at eppendorf
se and I will be your moderator for
today's webinar
if you want to know more about our
ependorf bioprocess Solutions visit our
website at
www.ependorff.com bioprocess I encourage
you all to participate today by
submitting any questions you might have
during the presentation but before I
will hand over now to our great speaker
Haka today
I would like to do my job first actually
and ask you two short marketing related
questions
so everyone who is joining now you
should see the first poll question and I
would like to know from you before you
register for this webinar
um just curious to know if you were
aware of our ependorf bioprocess
Solutions
I will give you some time to realize
that it's not listening only but also
some work for you to do but no worries
it's just one out of two questions and
the only other thing you need to do
afterwards is listening to the
presentation and type in your questions
and why we are waiting
I can try to
view the results
so thank you
for the first answer
um
let me quickly check here
for you interesting as well to see maybe
so it's nice to see that at least the
ones who realized that you're not only
listening today but also working
outside the question whether yes this is
of course really nice to know the second
question for us is um I would like to
get to know you better in terms of um if
this webinar you registered for is also
helping you so which of the following
anthos best fits to your current
situation
are you working or doing research and
development currently in 2D systems or
are you already working in 3D systems or
are you considering to switch from 2D to
3D
so
take your time have a look
and feel free to answer
if you are doing research and
development and 2D systems I'm pretty
sure you will learn a lot today
about how steel tank systems can improve
your process if you are already working
in steel systems listen to her and take
the opportunity to ask any question you
want to know to improve your process and
to get expert in hints and if you are
considering to switch from 2D to 3D
the same is true Hawker will answer you
all your questions
yeah the results so far some results are
still popping him I'm not sure if this
is
um updating after it's pushed live
thank you for your answers and with this
I'm already done with them let's say
marketing part and the scientific part
will start now I will hand over to my
colleague he is our cell culture
cell culture as well and cell and gene
therapy expert in our applications team
in anfield and he did most of the work
all of the work he will present to you
now so the stage is yours
yeah thank you Larry my name is Jorge
escowar and it's certainly a pleasure to
be here today and welcome everyone
to Spirit Bank bioreactors in vaccine
development producing AV particles and
covid-19 is by protein in suspension
some cultural webinar
so today I'm very happy to introduce
solo to our newest applications in in
vaccine development
so I'm going to start with signing from
today's slides about vaccines the state
of the art benefits and Industry growth
also in this talk I will be I will give
an overview of some of the most
important boxing platform
and finally I'm going to introduce most
of the relevant information about two
vaccine applications that were developed
recently in our application lab who are
related to adino Associated buyers aav
beta production and the second one about
the SARS Kobe 2 x sub uh Spike protein
production
so let's start
so as many of you know a vaccine is a
preparation used to stimulate the body
immune immuno response again diseases so
it can be administered mainly
intramuscular injections of bad oral and
nasal Administration is also possible
so vaccines help eradicate diseases in
the past and today prevent between two
and three million deaths a year
worldwide as you see in the slide data
from the CDC shows that how effective
vaccines have been in relocating major
diseases in the United States
for example in 2020 there were no report
cases of smallpox of paralytic polio for
example compare uh to the other average
of 29 000 cases and 16 000 cases in the
20th century respectively
so a wide progress in in eradicating
measles as well has spelled recently in
recent years
probably due to the growing and Cat
decision about vaccines and if morbidity
is nowhere near to the annual cases
since in the 20 in the 20th century when
half million people were in fact in the
average year
so it is well known that pandemic
outbreaks have occurred intermittently
since times immemorial damaging
communities socially and economically
and causing large number of
the image represents the timeline
of various contagious viral outbreak in
the world from the Spanish Flu to the
recent covid-19 pandemic that has been
effectively infected nearly
620 million people and killed more than
6.5 million people so far
so the new coronavirus is sled daily but
far more transmissible than Merc and
sounds coming and uh for sure we're
going again
vaccines have been effective preventing
and protecting people from getting
seriously ill or being hospitalized and
also protecting people against new new
audience
according to to this analysis market
analysis the vaccine Market size is
expected to evaluate valued in 28
billion dollars by 2026. uh with a
progressing growth of 4.13 percent
so the largest segment of the market are
probably like the vaccines and the
operative vaccines
and nearly 48 of the market growth will
be originated in North America
specifically in U.S and and Canada but
you will see that this region will the
road will be slower than the grow in the
market in the European
Asian operation
and companies like Stella Pharma Astra
Seneca America and others will be and or
are the most important players in the
field
now I'm going to give an overview of
some of the most important vaccine
platforms
so this schematic representation shows
different vaccine platform for
infectious diseases showing different
vaccine technology again uh byte of
pathogens by sayings can be classified
as live or dead vaccines and also
according to the platform used in their
manufacturing so see you can see many
examples in in this picture
conventional vaccines use antigen
derived from disabled weakened are
pathogens and or their components such
as subunit protein to generate an immuno
response to possible future in
specifically the proteins with unit
vaccine instead of using the entire
pathogens they include components or
antigens that the best stimulated immune
system so this strategy often require
the incorporation of adjuvants to elicit
astronomer response because antigen
alone are not enough to induce long-term
immunity
also eventually the antigen is digest
but under yet present in cells such as
the indeed cells as you've seen in this
picture which present the anti-yen for
recognition by being an assistant then
the T cells help the the T helper cells
will recruit another immunocell such as
the B cells which will produce specific
antibodies against the antigen
billing then these uh antibodies uh will
um
uh attack you know the videos uh that is
uh you know in the in the whole cells
and and they will tag the patreon for
Destruction by microphages also and
keyless cells on the other hand uh we
will have also B and D in human cells
remain in the body after infection to
provide immunological memory
as you see many FDA approved vaccines
another candidate in pre-clinical and
clinical trials in the world are
produced using conventional basic
technology so this is the case that for
example
uh because you know the live I don't
know the whole inactivate and
recombinant subunits and also some
candidates coming 19 recent coming 18
candidates uh that have been produced
using these the SE technology however
this strategy is often not sufficient
again complex pathogen like this coming
like our recent coming 19 and they can
evade the immune system and also provide
short-term immunity that require
repeated inoculation and take more time
to manufacture
the developer of vaccines against
emerging pathogens with pandemic
potential is not visible using this
conventional technology as I mentioned
before and also due to the manufacturing
problems I think that we have learned
some lessons from the recent covid-19
pandemic for example that the global
manufacturing capacity was limited to
answer uh
to to you know to
somehow answer the demand that you know
the patients needed and um
also consequently we must be prepared
for future but they'll know Remain the
greatest challenge so you we don't know
what is coming
and as a result uh this is really
important to develop platform that can
be applied rapidly to respond to
pandemic threat and that also in fact
again emerging variants
another important to highlight is the
scale of capabilities they should be
ready after vaccine development
selecting the most efficient platform to
increase the vaccine production in most
geographical areas
by the vector for gene therapy and the
use of nucleic acids uh like uh
messenger RNA vaccines half unable to
develop a novel vaccine platform to meet
the criteria against emerging uh
pathogens uh the aim of both
Technologies is to transfer fragments of
this genetic code taken from the target
pathogen into the patient cells and the
cells will produce uh you know the
antibodies and induced animal response
in the body
so one of the next generation of
buckling platform is divided by thomasin
and is one of the most popular uh
platform engine therapy today
divided Vector vaccines are bioparticles
unable to produce or cause any disease
and they don't pose any Hazard to our
the human body
these by the particles contain the gene
of Interest as you can see in this slide
of the select pathogen and this
particular genetic material is
transferred into the cell by the by the
vector to induce the immuno response
against the chosen patient so this is I
would like to highlight this that these
viral particles are called capsids
but how does the divided vaccine uh and
divide of vector vaccines work so as you
know know the vaccines are designed to
introduce antigen to the body so some
vaccine train the cells to produce
antigen themselves and this is the case
of these by the vector strategy
uh the vector is delivering the body and
the gases fuse in the cell membrane are
released in the genetic information then
later on the cells will read the
instruction
and express the target protein that
finally is exposed in the cell surface
the mere helper cells trigger an immune
response and recruit B cells to produce
antibodies again the target protein
and
um
yeah and finally this antibody attack
cell displaying the protein and Destroy
them and also there are non-living
memory cells enabled to switch and
respond for future infections
also another example is the RNA vaccine
is another really example of the next
generation of vaccine platform I think
that we all know a little bit about the
MRNA vaccine and how it works but let me
talk a little bit more about it
the messenger RNA is the cell blueprint
for building protein it's a single
strain RNA molecule that encode
generating information from DNA to be
translated into functional protein
molecule so the combination of this RNA
with the next relation of drug Delivery
Systems such as living nanoparticle
really facilitate the delivery of uh the
MRNA in the cells and also this is a
huge opportunity and a great platform uh
for the delivery of a wide range of next
generation of drugs to to patients
but the heard of the MRNA vaccine works
so it's pretty similar to the vector but
as I mentioned the MRNA will be
delivered to the cells using the
repeated particle and then the also the
entire mechanism is almost the same so
again the idea is to train the cell to
produce anti-in themselves
gain the immunohelper cells triggered an
immune response and recruit B cells to
produce antibodies again uh the target
protein and finally the B cells produce
antibody and they tag the cell
displaying protein and Destroy and
Destroy them
so there are some examples by the vector
vaccines and RNA vaccines that are
already approved by the Ava and some of
them are very popular today for example
the modern covid-19 vaccine the bio
biotech Pfizer coming 19 vaccine we have
the Johnson and Johnson covid-19 vaccine
that was developed by using the right
and Vector extraordinary and then we
have the Ebola the Ebola vaccine
so developing preventive Solutions
through new vaccine platform that
responds to new diseases is is really an
important uh challenge today
in order to produce high quality
biotherapyotics process development
involves around demanding components as
you see here including cost
cell line development small scale
exploration effective scaling and
optimization of offstream Downstream
processes
bus in production can be accomplished
but with either adherent or suspension
cell line but each option really require
a specific design and upstream and
downstream processing
so when you contribute using encourage
dependent cells the procedure is really
morally labor intensive and the
attachment culture lack of large-scale
bioreactor manufacturing solution if you
compare that with suspension culture
also they saw the association step is in
the process it's uh you know will
complicate This Cloud process and imply
a higher costs
we really believe that in order to meet
the growing demand of vaccine adapting
and chorus dependencies into suspension
cell closure easy manufacturing strategy
that could really simplify the Upstream
workflow and increase tighter yield
while producing reducing costs
um
yeah the process development involved
um in the process uh uh you know it's
important to to the selection of the
host cells and is one of the key factors
and it's important to know if
capabilities and properties so including
its ability to grow even in suspension
or adhere to a substrate
so as many of you know a human embryonic
units heck as everybody knows for
example have a wide range of advantages
including low maintenance
uh rapid proliferation robustness and
convenient application to both transient
and and unstable
expression
the hexel line Hector 93 cell line is
one of the most versatile mammalian cell
line with a wide range of application
including expression of recombinant
proteins antibodies and and Micron
vectors
of course are needed in order to meet
the lower demand as I said before and
especially on the the current governing
pandemic and within three series of
posture of new or new pattern
uh to this end we uh uses a suspension
attacked 1993 cell line that is called
XP 293f sunlight as a single culture
platform in the development of two
examples of bioreactor-based vaccines
application so one of them is the arena
Associated buyers vector and the other
one is the source copy 2 x approx Pi
protein production
so in the second half of this
presentation I'm going to introduce
details about how we establish a
suspension attack a293 is online as a
cell platform for vector and it's by
protein production using our newest
controller survey Siberia 2 and
bioreactor control system
so the application node 447 from 2021
demonstrate that a suspension adapter
hack293
is rewards suspension cell line capable
of achieving high self productivity and
in this case we were able to get 13
million cells per milliliter in nine
days I really encourage you to uh and
invite you to use this QR code and
download the application note so you
will find a lot of information and
really details about this uh this
development
so let's start with aav Vector
production platform example
the content of this example is
collecting and also in the application
node 450 of this year entitled Arduino
Associated virus production in
suspension sub torture using sayori
bioreactor
bioprocess controller again using the
the QR code Uganda loan information and
that would be really useful you will
find really detailed information about
where I'm planning to explain is playing
now
so we have previously described how
Vector base bikes in were let me explain
in detail the AV capsic production and
strategy so this is a as you see in in
the fly this is the capsic production
workflows the process included uh
several steps like plasmic selection
cell expansion plasmid transfection
Vector uh bile and Vector production
isolation and unquantification
so in this case
um we decided to produce aav2 capsids
because are the most widely used vectors
in pre-clinical and clinical stories
also this Vector has high safety rating
due to the fact that at one time a b is
not currently known to cause any disease
in India
so as I mentioned uh the first step is
the the plasmid selection DAV vectors
production involves three plasmids the
transfer plasmid the ribbon cup plasmid
and the helper plasmid
so in the case of the term for plasmid
this plasma contain basically the gene
of interest and is used to amplify or
produce medical bill pistine during the
transaction process
the replica plasmid is the plasmid that
contains the AV structural and packaging
genes the replication and and the
capacity the capsic genes
and finally the helper plasmid uh
contained adenovirus genome that is
necessary for recombinant aav polishing
regardless to the relevant card genes
two important details here that I would
like to to highlight
we have used in this application only to
plastic the red and card and Helper
because we wanted to produce emptic
acids and also we use uh the adenos to
survivors helper-free system and again
you will find more information in the
application node but essentially the
helper system eliminate the requirement
for wire type I don't know why is
co-infection
and only provision adenovirus helping
factors for aav polishing
the Second Step was the seller's pension
as I mentioned before we use the
suspensional ACT
29 increase the line the XP 293 f as a
cell culture platform we have grown the
cells in the bioglue 1C single used by a
reactor control but our newest cyber
twin bioreactor control system
so let me let me explain a little bit
more the process in detail
before running this payment uh we have
to consider and prepare a three
important components at the inoculum the
bioreactor and the controller
so let me explain a little bit more
about inoculum privilege
so this inoculum preparation will take
around almost around two weeks we
started with the sales expansion process
in the Shaker as is shown in in this
picture so we go to the cells in the New
Brunswick s41i a CO2 incubator Shaker at
37 Celsius it is eight percent of CO2
and 125 RPM of validation
we obtained more than 900 million cells
in the third passage and during this
expansion uh process we kept all the
inauguration density percentage feel of
the J plus and other parameter constant
so finally we prepared inoculin
containing 400 million shares in 200
milliliters of FB 293f expression median
of on each inoculation model
I want to highlight that here we
inoculate we run two experiments at the
same time and this is one of the coolest
features that our newest controller has
and but I will explain a little bit more
about that later
so the second one is my reactor
so the day before the inoculation we
have connected the ba sensor to Siberia
Twain bioreactor control system
we perform the calibration process
according to uh the operation manual
using buffer Solutions of pH 7 and 4 uh
zero and span respectively then the pH
sensor was disconnected and sterilize
after that after being sterilized the
sensors
we are faded each bioglue 1C and keep it
with a single Beach blue impeller with
those pH sensors
and we inserted the BS sensors in the PG
13.54 under aesthetic conditions inside
of course the biosafety cabinet
in addition we also connect a
parallelographic dual sensors and
excel's condenser a forecast mixing line
connect to the gas sparse port and also
a silicon tubing extension connect to a
different liquid addition Port so one
that you know we have in the in the bio
one for inoculation one for the base
addition and another for the addition of
antifone
then we place the royal blue one C by
reactors in the respected temperature
control block to keep the system at
content temperature
and finally we add 800 milliliter of the
medium into each bioreactor and
conditioned for at least 24 hours under
the parameters unset Point list in the
table that you can see here in the slide
finally 24 hours after conditioning we
inoculated both of my own C single used
by Reactor with the nobler so 200
milliliters uh of this inoculum
described previously containing four
hundred thousand cell per milliliter
with a some viability more than 95
percent
but we said also the temperature at 37
Celsius degree and we have control that
we saw of of CNR 14 uh 40 percent
finally you know the BH uh was
controlled uh using the Cascade that you
can see here in in this Slide by
basically using CO2 and sodium per
carbonate
also we took a sample
um from the bioreactor daily and measure
the pH the cell viability and density as
well as the concentration of different
metallic uh offline
so this is our newest controller
Siberian bioreactor control system
it is capable of controlling up to two
single use or glass bioreactor either
individually or in parallel
using a wide range of my reactor size
with a working volume ranging from 1.3
to 40 liters either way from microbial
or circuits
so the next step in the workflow is the
plasmic transfection and divided Vector
production
see that three days after the bioreactor
inoculation we raise the transfection
cell density of approximately three
million Circle milliliters so we have
decided to do an operation and that uh
at 3 million cell payment meter then uh
plasmid you know the two plasmid that we
use at certain ratio were diluted in the
medium I mean the XP 293f expression
medium and then in this case we have
used Factory as a transfection region at
certain radio and then that solution uh
that expression the transaction mix was
added into the plasmid and the median
solution incubated uh for a certain
period of time at room temperature and
finally added to the transfection uh
this transmission means was added to uh
to each bioreactor
we have observed a rapid increase of
cell growth involved by reactor between
days one and four of culture as you can
see in in the right of uh picture
reaching a big in viable cells density
at 7 million uh cells per million
I also want to to point out that the
process in both bioreactors so lower
cell grow after transfection if we
compare with the bioreactive process
without any transaction
as I mentioned before you know the
information that you will find in the in
the application node 447 uh of the last
year but essentially we we were able to
reach 13 million cells per milliliter
uh in that case
also we have determined here the
consumption of glucose and the
production of latte and an ammonia daily
during the whole during the whole
product
then finally uh let me explain a little
bit more about the isolation and the
quantification so in terms of the av2
capsule isolation
so 72 hours after the tram fraction we
collected 60 milliliters of the cell
medium and and the cells that were of
course in the bioreactor welding a bag
with the cell line to one of our
bioreactor liquid addition parts
so the cells were centrifuge and we
separated the cell valid and
subordinated
and then we use AV Pro Max heat
purification kit and again I encourage
you to find more information in the
application node in this case the kit
was used to isolate and purify the 82
capsids in the cell parent and in the
supernative uh following the
manufacturer of protocol instructions
so following the particle isolation we
quantify the total amount of capsid in
the cell palette and in the supernetic
using aav2 Express Elisa kit
we have upstairs here lower ab2 capsic
title from the supernatural compared to
the cell pellet in the Navy 2 production
process from both bioreactors uh we
obtain a very similar every title from
both by reactors demonstrating an
excellent reversibility of the AV
production using our Precision
controller bioreactors
finally I would like to explain the
second example
uh that we have uh you know prepared for
you today and this will be the source
copy 2 examples by protein production
so they're going 19 pandemic uh is
ongoing and he is far from being over
and with degrees of the uh risk of
exposure to new battling more scalable
vaccine Productions strategy are needed
to me this Global demand as I mentioned
before
those two universities all include part
of the partying
for example the covid-19 vaccine
contains by protein s protein which is
recognized by our immune system and
triggered immune response including
antibodies and white blood cells that
will fight the virus after being
vaccinated
so as you see this schema this is a
schematic representation of the Spy
protein production
and potential immunization so starting
from the production of the plasmids
after they are using the plasma for the
cell transfection the cells will produce
sorry
the antibodies and then of course this
is uh you know an immunization potential
immunization cycle you know the humans
will get immunized and then the whole
mechanism is the same that as I
explained uh before
um in the right side you see a market
analysis that these market analysis has
conclude that the global through unit
vaccine Market
is anticipated to grow around 11 during
the forecast period of 20 20 22 2028
in this regard our company offer a wide
range of product and Technical guidance
such as this application loads to help
our customers achieve their goals
the entire workflow of the Stars uh Kobe
spy protein production which includes
cereal step
uh from the plasma production cell
expansion and plasma transfection to a
spike uh purification titration is
represented here in this in this slide
the exoproplasmid was produced in our
lab the plasmate has E coli was expanded
by fermentation usage a flask
level of plasmid for the bioreactor
transaction years
we use the same subcultural platform so
we use the HP 293 excellent
transfectable cells using the X approval
plasma to produce uh the Cyrus Kobe
expired protein and finally the protein
was purified using a straight tact
interesting and characterized by Elisa
and SDS page as you see so let me
explain a little bit more in detail as
the process
we're not doing preparation bioreactor
can be conditioning and say where you're
doing controllers at all was identical
to the AV Vector uh production example
that I just uh you know shared with you
but in this case we have carried out a
million optimization study and finally
decided to use hack VIP NX cell
commercial Medium as you see in the
table
the owner by reactor condition remaining
the same
so we you know
you know we as before so approximately
400 000 uh cell per milliliter and carry
out the transfection and they do uh at
approximately a million square per
milliliter as you see in this in picture
uh we use two different uh we obtaining
two different uh Global files uh using
again two different transaction regions
in this case we use factorial as before
and then uh also Vector Pro that is a
specific developed or design for protein
for building production
so when you use infect aware a rapid
increase of the cells grow also observed
up to day seven of culture reaching a
pig environment cells density around
sorry
9.5 million cell per milliliter in the
case of factopro the cell grow profile
was affected compared to the factorial
transaction
so reaching in this case 6.6 million
cells a per milliliter at day eight
so I would like to highlight here that
both by reactors show a lower cell grow
after transfection compared to the uh
you know the XP 293f cell grow in one
liter bioreactor under the same
condition as I explained before you know
that information that is uh uh you know
explained in the obligation node 447 of
last year
so finally we also analyze all the
concentration of metabolites on daily
bases
so every day uh until day five after
transfection 60 milliliter of sample
containing uh the cells and the medial
were collected using as before a bug and
this bag was well actually by reactor
liquid addition ports
the Southwest interview again and then
the supernatural was collected in this
case we have uh
isolated the the
yellow display protein from the
supernatural
uh then this pipe protein was purified
uh by Affinity chromatography
so after you know you can find I mean
the the application this application
though is not released yet but then I
can provide more information about all
this step later on so after this
purification is dead the pure spy
protein from the supernet was tighter so
the Human Service Kobe RBD Eliza kit and
this allies are antibody pair detects
SARS coming to Regional binding domain
RBD of the S1 super unit of the Spy
protein
then the answer I was conducted
according to the manufacturing protocol
in structure
despite protein concentration uh when
using Factor Pro as a component of the
transaction measure mixture was higher
around four milligrams per liter
compared to the very reactor in which
factorial was part of the transaction
measure in this case 3.5 million per
liter this pipe is lower growth of
infection
and finally we use SDS page to analyze
uh this pipeline produces involved by
reactor and as you can see here in this
in the picture uh both are both show
high Purity with apparent molecular
weight of 190 kilod icon after compared
with the standards
so I want to thank you I hope you
enjoyed the presentation and I will hand
over to David and we'll provide more
information about our bio product
solution
thank you for your presentation and um
thank you all for listening so far
before we will now start with the Q and
a session
um just a reminder if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and all questions that are
not answered today we will take the time
answer them VIA mail and we'll get in
contact with you afterwards
so to give you some time to ask the
questions you might have for the
different
sections um
I would like to show one last time the
severia twin and the bioblue
um bioreactors singularis directors HoHo
used in his experiments and he just did
show to you so first our survivor twin
our latest bioreactor control system
which is a really nice system where you
can control two bioreactors and parallel
or also individually in a quite broad
size range from one liter range to 40
liter range
and our bioblue single-use bioreactors
you did also see during the presentation
uh with a volume range from 100
milliliters to 40 milliliters both
um not both the wire blue vessels are
also available for fermentation
processes so uh in the Bible F version
with Russian and Palace and other
specifications compared to our cell
culture versions with the pitched blade
impellers
so and in the meanwhile I did see that
some questions
showed up in the shed
um asset on the far left corner of the
screen there's the Q and A Box
type in your question and I will start
now with the first question
but I can see here and this is uh what
is the filling volume you used and the
different experiments for the
bioreactors
well for bioreactor you should work
about the minimum working volume of the
vessel so that you can cover the sensor
that would depend off of the you know
the the where you're using but basically
you can work as I say about the minimum
working volume and then cover all the
same source
thank you another question that I can
see in the chat is why do you produce
empty capsids if one of the requirements
to produce a virus Vector vaccine is to
eliminate empty capsids
yeah that's a really good questions and
and I know that there is a safety issue
regarding
uh you know the percentage of empty
capsids in in the production but uh our
goal here uh in this application was to
develop what wasn't to develop a vaccine
candidate so I want to say that the main
goal is to help you know our customers
creating Simple Solutions on a workflow
for uh passing applications in in this
particular
and we have developed nav production
platform that can be easily customized
uh to produce uh in this case profit
like the vaccines so durability vaccines
or even can be useful for for uh gene
therapy
foreign
that just came in is in your experiments
what do you think is the main limiting
factor to scale up the process so the
aav production in a more robust and
efficient manner
so the main limiting factor to scale up
aav production
well there are many factors that uh you
know are involved in the in the in the
manufacturing of aav and I think that
you know
uh having a good platform is important
uh you know in order to produce all
these AV uh capsids and
um
yeah I think that this would be the main
part to consider you know during the
whole the the Upstream process having uh
the adequate uh cultural platform or
sell uh lime uh platform or soccer
platformer anyway to to know to to grow
the cells and obtain other AV in in you
know in a good conditions and I think
that will be one of the the main most
important factor to to consider
okay another question is why did you
conduct a cell culture media
optimization study on hexa Pro Spike
protein production
well uh this is a yeah another uh
interesting question and uh there was
also only a ghost and Factor related
decisions so you know if you know you
have to schedule the process uh because
would be important in order to you know
to to scale out the entire
um you know process so that was only a
cost effective related decision that we
took in the lab
okay thank you and
last reminder for everyone to ask your
questions otherwise I will come to the
last question I can see in the chat
which is I am surprised to see the
comparison between aav collected from
the Surplus and the supernatant raavs
not expect to diffuse into the cell
culture medium
yeah that's a really nice question and
unlike other hey we so we have there are
like uh many prototypes every third eye
but in this case I mean we should start
to produce hey V2 and 82 capsids are
really highly
retained within the sauce and uh in this
case you know the salt digestion metal
whatever you use is made to isolate the
cut sets
okay then there are no other questions
in the chat thank you again for your
time today today
thank you
thank you before we uh go ahead I would
like to thank you all for joining us
today and for the interesting questions
you all put in the chat questions we did
not answer we don't have doesn't matter
but um if you want to re-watch their
webinar it's available on demand here on
liproots and if you then have questions
just type them in and we will still see
them and answer them our next webinar on
antibody production and Bishop pastoros
by the way by the way will be next
week's on Thursday same time same
location as well if you want to register
for ependorf by process Spotlight
newsletter to stay informed on upcoming
events visit our app.wire process
website appinoff.com bio process and get
research information on like webinars
like today but also our information on
events such as the upcoming stem cell
Community Day in 2023
and with this I'll say thank you and
wish you all a nice and pleasant rest of
the day